all right guys
bang bang i've got robert here with me
thank you so much for doing this sir
yeah thank you for having me happy new
year yeah happy new year to you as well
let's jump right into your background
you spent some time in the military uh
then worked at pwc but where'd you grow
up how did you get to the military and
then why go
uh to pwc afterwards sure great great
question i
i grew up moving around a lot my dad was
in the hotel industry
so i lived and lived in europe so not a
military brat but pretty pretty
comparable
i joined the military very uh
not randomly but spontaneously
following 911 so i was in college during
9 11. so that that caused me to go into
the marine corps
um and they needed pilots so so i was a
helicopter pilot there for nine years
and then uh and then left joined pwc um
they were kicking off a big military
hiring initiative
and uh and that was really uh what
exposed me
to to a lot of the more traditional
financial services
side of things so i worked in their
banking capital markets group um
a lot of the post-financial crisis
regulations a big focus on
large-scale technology implementations
and risk management or other
regulatory compliance initiatives uh
and then uh and then was introduced to
luca through a mutual mutual friend
um and uh hadn't worked heavily in
crypto i was familiar i read the bitcoin
white paper and
you know bought a tiny amount wish i
bought more
and uh and then uh um
started off at luca a little over two
years ago now
formerly called called libra we changed
the name a few months into me joining
and they were creating institutional
grade software
and building data products that made
that helped to make the software
function and and that was very very
appealing to me in a rapidly growing
industry it was something that i knew
the industry or i thought
would get to eventually uh which is
one of the things i think we're going to
talk about today is as as mainstream is
is adopting all of this so at luca
we build institutional grade
software and data products to support
middle and back office operations
got it and so i know you're not the
founder of the business but
uh you lead it today help us understand
kind of the
impetus for uh the company's creation
and kind of what the original idea was
and how it
uh if it all has evolved to where you
are today
sure so so jake benson was my
predecessor and
and founder um he's still um involved
with luca um and uh he created the first
bitcoin tax calculator back in 2014.
um we kind of joked around that he was
the only person trying to pay his
capital gains on his bitcoin investments
back then um
and uh and really you know he discovered
very very quickly through a lot of
conversations that
the right use case there wasn't just a
bitcoin tax calculator but it was a
cryptocurrency tax calculator
because there was a lot of innovation
going on um
and uh and new assets being created on
blockchains
and then uh around 2017 company pivoted
towards
institutions it was a lot of the funds
had now been created by that time
and fund admin some of the smaller fund
admins were starting to
take on crypto fund clients
and so we built the first version of our
software we're now on the third
generation
built the first version of the
institutional grade software
with standards like aicpa sock controls
in mind as we were building it so that
we could support the
the businesses that were uh forming
around the crypto ecosystem
got it and as you started to uh
kind of get into these institutions uh
what are some of the major themes that
you're seeing right so the idea of
building software
at an institutional grade for kind of
middle and back office
to many people would seem unsexy uh and
frankly they don't understand it so kind
of when you go into
a corporation or an organization like
what what is the conversation like
what are the themes you're seeing uh and
kind of maybe how does that sentiment
shift even over the last year or so as
you've been uh
uh ceo so it's it's all about the data
um at to start so if we're working for a
customer and we're
we're trying to figure out whether it's
you know creating whatever type of
report they need
so if it's a fund they're trying to
strike nav or their their fund admin is
trying to strike
net asset value reports we'll we'll come
in first and collect
that customer's data from the ecosystem
um people that know the ecosystem know
that
it comes from a lot more places than
than traditional
um funds and so and that's that's one of
the great things about crypto and the
innovation that's going on and
they're trading and exchanging these
assets in new ways but that creates a
lot of
downstream challenges for the middle and
back office operations
um first just collecting all the data
second trying to
you know make sure bitcoin is bitcoin
you look at kraken calls bitcoin xbt
and uh and coinbase btc two of the
largest exchanges in the us
for the most commonly traded assets so
when you get to you know the other
seven thousand plus assets that that
funds are trading on today
it gets much more complex um and then we
fill in things like cost basis proceeds
so anything that requires fair market
value with the pricing data source
that our customers want we let them
choose from a number of them
including our fair market value our
proprietary fair market value
pricing product called luca prime and uh
and then ultimately we apply a bunch of
reconciliation steps and techniques to
make sure their data is accurate and
complete
so we can create a crypto sub ledger
effectively
and then from there we can do the things
that usually the customers are calling
us up to do
which is any of the reporting processes
helping them pass an audit
tax reporting financial statements
ledger entries
all the traditional financial
requirements
um that usually people take for granted
when they start
uh putting putting crypto assets into
their businesses
got it one of the things that's been
really interesting to me is
you just highlighted this uh kind of
very elementary problem of just hey if
two different exchanges call the same
asset two different names then that can
cause confusion
but also there's some much more nuanced
uh challenges so
uh one for example is an expanding
balance sheet potential right so if i
hold bitcoin on my balance sheet
and all of a sudden it's expanding uh in
kind of us dollar value and i report
in u.s dollar terms where does that go
uh in my financial statements or my
financial reporting
another is uh actually denominating
revenue when it comes to
crypto so rather than denominating the
revenue in dollars and saying hey i made
10
000 i may say i made you know a third of
a bitcoin and so
how does that kind of affect a lot of
this uh these accounting standards
how much of that today uh across all of
those different issues
are you know still complex obstacles
that people need to navigate
versus no we're getting to the point
where there's like some pretty good
standards here
and uh you feel pretty comfortable that
like corporations moving forward in the
public or private markets are going to
have like a nice foundation to stand on
and everyone kind of agrees on what what
that treatment and rules are
so absolutely like you pointed out we
have to apply some new techniques to
some of those situations to do some of
the very common things like establish
ordinary short-term income versus
capital gains or whatnot
i think that you know i'd say roughly
90 of that was figured out before defy
um you know once once we get into that
and that's one of the exciting things is
it's the next thing for everybody to
figure out and it's
it's it's causing a lot of innovation
but when it comes to the very basic
things which are the
what the majority of the portfolios make
up today so these are your
your mining applications your staking
applications so all that short-term
income
all the air drops that people experience
on a recurring basis
all the net capital gains that they get
um or
receiving an income and applying
something at fair market value i think
all of that is
is fairly straightforward we might be
missing
um very formal guidance but but it
doesn't mean that the standards aren't
there we do have
you know draft guidance i know the aicpa
has a ton of you know leadership groups
and has put out a ton of perspectives
um even a lot of our regulators or
government agencies in the u.s
like the irs with its faqs have matured
a lot
since for example two years ago that
define a lot of these things
uh so i'd say there's a lot of work to
go but the the basics and i think the
basic foundation
is there however with that said
it's still something that we explain
even as part of our very basic sales
pitch
uh almost every single time so i think
there's a lot more education to go but
the good news is is yeah a lot of those
basic functions
most of the standard setters agree on on
how we should address them
so one of the things that's interesting
to me is that we're going to digitize
the assets then there's this element of
decentralization and then ultimately
we'll get automation out of it right
where
people can interact with protocols
machines can transact with other
machines
and there ends up being just a more
efficient automated system
is there a world where we eventually get
to the software whether you guys are
building or other people's software
that can essentially do a lot of the
accounting functions
um and kind of what i'll consider
operations or middle or back office
in that same automated way so that
you're not settling the books at the end
of the month you're actually doing it
in a minute by minute or hour-by-hour
basis um
and there's kind of a more real-time
aspect to a lot of the flow of funds in
the financial metrics
absolutely we do same-day nav we
announced that in the press
over a year ago with hashtags so they
currently have one of their funds
that strikes nav every single day and
that's because we worked with them
uh maybe you know a little over a month
to sort out some of the
processes to make sure that their data
flowed in and that we could accommodate
that
um it gets much more complex the larger
the portfolio and really where your
trading activity gets into
you know mixed derivatives into it mix
defy and uni swaps and all these new
things that are coming out
makes it more complex so we still have
to figure those out but there's
absolutely a path forward to automate
the majority of those processes
or at a minimum highlight where there
isn't automation
and potentially replace them for the
interim until
until we build you know more advanced
features on a case by case
but there's a lot of that i will say a
ton of this data
is i'd say probably over 95 of the data
that we intake for our customers and we
have over 160 funds that that are
managed in our software today
uh pure crypto funds um
is uh most of that data is not
off chain so it is from privately held
centralized databases
so like that you would you know get over
a coinbase api or a cracking api or
or whatnot so a big portion of it is uh
is not on chain data for sure yeah
walk through some of the challenges with
dfi you mentioned that there are
challenges but
maybe just elaborate on one or two of
those that you guys are actively dealing
with
it's really the same thing that i just
mentioned is traditionally when someone
chooses a liquidity provider and that
liquidity provider has their data that a
customer can get over an api
in d5 that doesn't always exist there
isn't always a business that they're
interacting with or if there is
they're not necessarily recording the
data the data sets centralized they're
facilitating the exchange of it
and this depends on the you know the
product and what specific process
so i'd say with d5 we are dealing with a
lot more on-chain data
and whenever you're dealing with encha
data you're missing elements that people
take for granted you know there's not
going to be a us dollar value associated
with it usually
and so some of those very simple things
we have to fill in using some other
techniques
all definitely solvable but some of the
data isn't
as readily available and it's often much
more incomplete
than we need in order to satisfy some of
those reporting requirements
got it and then maybe we could talk a
little bit just about this idea that
you've previously said a lot of what
we're talking about today
was in the innovation labs inside these
organizations especially the large
corporations
um but now it's actually moving and
starting to hit the business unit so
we're moving from more of an r
d type thing more to an application on a
day-to-day basis
what are you seeing there and how do you
think about that transition
sure i think that's the the natural
evolution of the
the traditional financial institutions
adopting adopting something that's
that's this material right for their for
their businesses i mean a lot of the
things that's going on in the crypto
industry that
the crypto native ecosystem has been
doing for
you know you could argue a decade
probably materially maybe the last five
years
and and as these traditional financial
services companies are coming in
they're reading a lot of the technical
white papers they've got innovation labs
that are exploring a lot of things
i think the biggest thing and this is
advice that i give to any of the larger
financial institutions
that i speak to is to don't look as much
at the underlying technology look at the
ecosystem because that's where
that that's really what we're seeing a
lot of innovation as well
and um and that's what i think
if affects the the overall markets
and how people exchange these assets
today
that's different from what they're used
to seeing in the securities or fx
markets or you know whatever market you
want to compare it to
yeah it's fascinating to me how
um kind of quickly this is all evolving
and how quickly we're going from
uh oh there's this cute thing in the
crypto blockchain space to now wait we
actually may be able to implement this
in our
everyday business and it actually in
some weird way feels like that's
accelerating
is that fair from kind of your
perspective
absolutely we've been waiting for what
is happening right now before our eyes
for several years we didn't
we've been preparing for it we didn't
know when it was going to happen
specifically we were all hoping it was
going to happen soon
but it is kind of a domino effect i mean
even by lucca's
partnerships that we've we've announced
with state street leading our series c
this past winter and partnerships with
companies like smp
ihs market we have partnership with
cpa.com i mean those are all your
traditional logos that are
you know play a big very big roles in
the traditional financial services
ecosystem
and now some of the traditional funds
for example
get to use the the name brands that
they're used to seeing already
um to provide them services as they're
adding crypto to their portfolios and as
i don't have to tell you in the press it
seems like multiple times a day we see
someone is buying you know hundreds of
millions of bitcoin or some other crypto
asset we know it's bitcoin today i'm
sure that'll
that'll work its way down to the other
cryptocurrencies over the course of this
next year but
um but uh yeah very very very exciting
and then it's whether it's all the
regulation like what the occ's been
putting out
lately i mean allowing the custody of
assets
you know comparing what we're doing in
crypto to things
um like like fedwire and and uh
and whatnot is is really really exciting
you mentioned a couple of big milestones
that you've experienced lately let's
maybe talk about the fundraise first uh
you raised capital my understanding is
from state street
uh cpa.com and a couple of others uh
that maybe aren't considered your
traditional venture capitalists but are
very critical to
uh what you're building and uh kind of
the industry you're going after
talk through just the the partners in
that fundraise what the capital is going
to be used for and why select those to
partner with sure so you know all of
we named in in the press state street uh
cpa.com who we'd already been partnered
with for for over a year and we go to
market with them
um for our luca tax for professionals
product and then smp and
all of those we were talking to um in
commercial relationship capacities
before investments and we were raising
our series c last year
uh so our you know those big
partnerships are natural companies to
speak to
and so we wanted to focus on that
particularly in our press release
because we thought it would help the
industry and help with some of the
adoption
um and uh and then from there we do it
we do have other investors
that were involved in the rounds that we
didn't name that that aren't part of
commercial
relationships but the use of the capital
honestly
is just to further improve our products
we've already built our products we're
on the third generation
we're actually just launching um some of
them more publicly over the course of
the next couple weeks in advance of tax
season and
and uh um and uh but they're not all tax
focused products i mean we do have
the next generation of our institutional
software that we're putting out
we plan on improving it to add all the
features that our customers are asking
for related to defy
very very quickly so that they can start
using them right away
and benefit from their their back
offices being organized
as they're adopting some of these new
financial products
um and uh and then continuing to
um scale our scale our footprints um so
it's pretty honestly the use of the
capital is pretty basic it's just the
to to expand our business continue to
execute
and uh and support our customers with
features
you don't happen to want to name the
people you didn't name previously right
now do you
um not right now but we will probably
uh it's soon in the press
so just so that i don't uh prematurely
you know
share some of that so we will be doing
it um but we're just gonna be doing it
here in here in the near future that
we've already uh that we're already
working on a strategy around
no problem i i didn't expect you to but
i gotta ask
uh another part uh that you've done and
announced publicly is this partnership
with the s p
um and there's some indexes and some
other work maybe talk a little bit just
about
uh kind of that relationship
specifically and some of the stuff that
you publicly announced
so we are providing our luca reference
data
and luca prime among among other data
products to
smp to support them as they create
their indices um for crypto uh they
haven't announced
specifically what what the indices will
be yet but that there will be several of
them
um they're gonna be coming out very soon
here
um which we're very very excited about
and uh and we're hoping that this is
just the the beginning of
of our relationship with them they're uh
a great logo that we know is very very
trusted
and and that's a big part of our
relationship is making sure that the
data quality of our products
can serve the companies like s p and all
of our other customers
and meet those traditional institutional
standards so that they can
continue doing what they're doing um but
hopefully with with
crypto assets involved in a much more
material way
got it and would it be fair to say that
majority if not all of the
business for you is really b2b uh
whether you're going b2b and providing
software to those middle and back
offices
uh or you're providing these data feeds
and kind of reference data
to somebody like an s p and then they
may go b to c so that's more of like a b
to b to c type model
or do you actually have direct touch
points with retail in any of the
products
really all of the above now so a couple
examples and our foundation to be clear
is absolutely b2b
right we cater to our institutions a lot
of the biggest the biggest uh logos in
the crypto industry
and you know are now starting to see the
the traditional side of things enter
but additionally so for example with our
cp.com partnership
that's more of a b2b to see so we built
a product for them
to sell to or licensed to cpa firms
who are supporting their clients so
that's an example of our b2b2c
um we have in a pre-launch mode and
we'll be announcing it
very soon here in the next week a free
portfolio management tool
that is a consumer product that's
absolutely free
um which we believe will help support
the industry and there's some very
inexpensive tax add-ons
so if they need to do tax reporting on
top of that it'll be extremely cost
effective
for the retail so in that example we are
going direct
b2c um and uh and we'll continue to
build those out but really it's all with
the same standards that b2b requires
which is a big part of our strategy it's
part of our culture
we built to our aicpa stock controls and
all the standards that the institutions
rely on
we want consumers and the retail markets
to benefit from as well
yeah it makes a lot of sense too i guess
like once you get the b2b
uh relationships and you're really able
to establish yourself
uh but from a product standpoint and
accuracy uh a
resiliency and and um and also kind of
this validation to then move kind of
downstream into the retail market as
well is that
generally how you're thinking about it
perfectly said that's that's exactly
exactly what we intend to do there are
there's a ton of innovation that goes on
in the crypto industry and so you get a
ton of startups
a ton of companies that are doing great
things
however when we start doing things to
institutional standards it becomes much
more challenging it's much more costly i
mean even just our annual audit costs
to maintain our aicpa sock standards are
higher than a traditional startup would
be
without a doubt um but that's what's
required in order to build that quality
of a product
and so the standards
that we support there are a big part of
our value prop a big part of our
marketing campaigns and everything that
we do
and it's honestly one of the challenging
things too because people think because
they're selling you something
that the calculations are correct but i
can tell you that they're not
um and uh and and we want to make sure
that we can put products out there
that that people can trust and that are
accurate and that they can support and
that they're very comfortable using
when they're filing their taxes or doing
any of those other things that could
potentially put them at risk if they get
it wrong
absolutely i gotta ask uh for somebody
who was a
helicopter pilot in the marines to uh to
running
uh this business what are some of the
similarities
and also some of the biggest differences
uh between those two jobs
sure that's a great question you know at
the end of the day
both of them just come down to problem
solving
and same thing i was doing at pwc
and that you know consultants the ones
that you can that you can trust and that
you rely on
you know in the normal course of your
business um are helping you there to
solve the most challenging problems
um or to improve processes and that's
exactly what we're doing at luca is
we're taking what is a very complex
problem
at the end of the day and we're trying
to make it as simple as possible
um for our customers and uh
in making sure that we focus on on their
needs first you know same thing as a
helicopter pilot you know our customer
was different in that case it was the
you know the ground troops or the
infantry or um anyone on the grounds
that we're supporting
um it's it's the same same premise here
as we're solving problems so that they
can rely on us
so we're in i consider our company to be
in a support position
to other companies businesses for sure
before we move into the uh uh kind of
lightning round to finish up
uh i just want to zoom out a little bit
and you guys obviously have built a
great business
uh there's a lot of commercial partners
and customers that
trust you on a day-to-day basis uh
really to run their business and kind of
fulfill that support position you just
described where
are we going right when we start
thinking about digital assets
decentralized protocols kind of this
automated financial system
from your perspective how does the
business evolve and kind of what
role can you guys eventually uh kind of
uh
move into and serve for the industry as
it you know not only brings in kind of
more adoption both in institutional and
retail space but also different types of
assets different types of mechanisms
and kind of really moves to digitize
most of the legacy financial system
so i mean as as this our industry is
moving fast right now and particularly
in the last
six months i like to say that it's that
it's picked up a lot here
which is exciting to see and i usually
resist a little bit when people say hey
this is a new asset class or things like
that you know this is this is a new
technology that can change the way that
all assets are managed globally
potentially in the future
and when or if that happens i don't know
i think that asset management and asset
exchange
can benefit from this technology and
when i say technology i don't mean just
blockchain but it's the way that the
ecosystem is exchanging these assets i
mean
if we can create new ways to access
assets across borders and increase the
liquidity of those assets
and allow people to exchange them for
one another in a marketplace
that's very very exciting i mean you can
apply it to real estate
debt um i mean you know anything that's
uh that has a store of value associated
with it and ultimately create a
marketplace that exchanges these assets
in a new way compared to what we've seen
before
now that makes some of these back office
operations more challenging
so that's where luca comes into the
picture and we plan on
you know stay bleeding edge um for the
middle and back office operation space
so that the innovators can keep
innovating and uh
and in creating a new way that ideally
assets are exchanged globally in in the
future um so that's that's really
the future that we see we know we're
seeing it in a very very material way
today
um already um but it's got a long way to
go
clearly right in the in the larger
ecosystem
for sure uh three questions i'd ask
everyone and you'll get to ask me one
question to uh to finish up the first is
what is the most important book that
you've ever read
great question um so my first reaction
here
is uh gates of fire which is uh
about the the battle of thermopylae in
the in the 300 which i know everyone's
seen in the movie but that
doesn't do justice to this book um and
it's just
you know an example of uh setting the
right examples of leadership
of standard setting um that really
fits into the overall culture of an
organization
that's a great answer uh second question
is a question that's sponsored by
eight sleep they basically have a
thermoregulation mattress that makes it
super cold
i previously uh was not into sleep i
used to fly around the country a bunch
and basically beat up my body and these
guys convinced me hey you probably
should sleep eight hours
uh and this helps you basically sleep in
a much deeper kind of more plentiful way
what's your sleep uh kind of regiment or
has anything changed over the years
especially going from the military
uh to pwc and now here uh anything that
you've kind of changed over time
yes i sleep less i think um is this true
really
i thought that i would get used to
sleeping less from the marine corps
and i think it just made me miss sleep
more instead
um but i've gotten used to acclimating
to it but i think that the bigger
takeaway kind of like you hit it on the
debt
on the head for your sponsor um that
should be a short term right learn how
to manage it but you you can never
replace actual sleep so
i'll have to uh i'll have to check out
this mattress because
um i absolutely could benefit from it
how many hours do you think you sleep at
night
uh probably i'm averaging five
now i'm i'm usually happy if i can get
six to seven
so never okay never continuously
but yeah and uh the one
uh variable is always uh i see a
trampoline in the background so i'm
assuming you have young children
who who probably are uh not making this
easy for you
no that's definitely a challenge i think
they they help
and uh um they help keep the focus
though for
for sure so they don't necessarily help
sleep
i love it uh last question a little bit
more fun
aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer
i i don't see how there there could be
a universe that big without them i think
so i break it down to statistics
when i do that which is usually the way
that i that i approach answers like that
so if i had to
if i had to go one way or another i
would say yes i believe that they are
out there somewhere
so maybe the uh the nasa astronauts that
are gonna venture to mars will
will prove us right in some capacity
soon
yeah i i agree that there's some way i
don't know if i believe that they've
come to earth
and haven't revealed themselves or
anything crazy like that but uh
i definitely need to have arms and legs
or eyes but i think there's something
out there
i love it you could ask me one question
to wrap up what do you got for me
sure i'd say um you know where
uh what do you think is going to be the
the biggest milestone in crypto in 2021
specifically 2021
um i think we see a fortune 50 company
put uh
bitcoin on their balance sheet or at
least fortune 100.
um you know i don't know which one
necessarily
uh we're recording this kind of
mid-january 2021.
uh if you said to me right now what's
the next big public company to do it's
probably tesla
um but if you said to me you know pick
one that is
uh kind of nobody would expect i'm not
sure i could do that
uh but definitely somebody does it or at
least that would kind of be the
big milestone and then once you get kind
of all the corporations starting to do
it in some form or fashion
uh i think the next one is just like
what's the first central bank
to not only do it but to do it and kind
of publicize it right you know
some people would argue hey look
somebody probably has already done it
but to really come out and say hey look
we're doing this here's our thesis
behind doing it and
we're committed to this i think would be
you know kind of you went from uh
retail investors to kind of now you got
these institutional financial service
companies
uh you'll then get you know more
traditional corporations publicly traded
companies and then eventually you'll get
the central banks
um so those are kind of the next two
milestones but i don't foresee a
central bank making that move in 2021
sure
i'd buy that all right man well robert
listen thank you so much for uh for
doing this where can we send people to
find you on the internet or find out
more about luca
uh sure so uh luca.tech um is where you
can find our website and you can find
all of our social social
social outlets there as well for our
various products depending on what type
of customer you are
and that's uh l-u-k-k-a dot tech
awesome and uh anywhere to send them to
find you
i am actually not on social media just
uh just with the company
yep i love it that that is uh that's an
easy way to make sure everyone goes to
the
company website absolutely that's better
than going to my personal one anyway
all right man listen thank you so much
for taking the time to do this robert
we'll have to do it again in the future
yeah happy to come back anytime thanks
for having me